so everyone knows they're here for
tutorial on visualization with
bouquet I will give it yay so I'll hand
it over to
Christina um
enjoy hi
yeah so good morning um I'm hopefully
you all more comfortable in this room um
no
pressure um so I'm glad there's this
excitement uh about learning bokeh and
visualizations in Python and I'm glad
that you're all decided to choose this
talk um so the title of the talk is
interactive data visualizations with
python
um um a little bit about me I also work
at Continuum analytics and my data
scientist there I'm originally from
Barcelona but I'm living in Austin Texas
right now I just uh flew here uh
yesterday morning so I'm still a little
bit jet laed
um uh my a little bit about my
background um I started a master didn't
finish it because I joined Continuum um
and I couldn't reject the offer um in
Data Mining and bi uh before that I was
a process engineer at Proctor in gamble
doing a lot of data analysis for uh
operations search and Manufacturing
processes and after that I was a
business analyst for a bank in Spain um
I I did uh a master in industrial
engineering at UPC Barcelona and I I
actually did my master thesis at uh
evera aen uh for six months at the Yan
Energy Research Center I have this
website where you can find several of
other of my talks I gave um recently uh
another talk at a p data event uh in
Dallas
uh on cond and how you can use cond for
um your data science
projects so let's start about uh just
giving an introduction to bokeh how many
people here have uh heard about the
library
before how many have used
it okay um so kind of my my goal um here
today for this tutorial I know it's not
very comfortable um to work on your
laptop here so kind of uh it's going to
be kind of like EXT the talk and there's
a lot of examples that you can try to
run yourself I'm not going to make it
very heavily on you writing a lot
because the conditions uh you know you
don't have tables and it can be a little
uh uncomfortable uh and and I don't see
everyone having uh their laptop here but
we I'm going to point you to the
examples where they are how you can run
them how you can tweak them um to do
whatever they are um so the act the goal
for today is get you to know um Boke uh
point you to the right direction
so you know what to look for in the
library for the things that you might
need um and I have to say they've
they've done a great Improvement in the
documentation in recent um recent uh
months um and so the the Boke p.org it's
where the documentation is hosted and
you can go there and uh and and search
for whatever you need they're also
pretty active in the mailing list so if
you have any questions there's a a great
a very large team um at bokeh that's
growing and that they give feedback um
you know pretty fast and the community
is growing too so there's uh also other
people that are in learning bouqu can
also provide you some some
guidance um so the there's a actually a
Boke organization GitHub and where all
the repositories are and uh a Twitter
account if you want to uh you know um
shout shout out at the developers of
Boke and tell them how awesome they are
so first let's kind of take a look what
what what Boke is and if you go to the
GitHub repository the organization
you're going to see several repository
not just one so I kind of want to
introduce it and and um make sure you
understand uh what this Boke um
ecosystem is so mainly as we we um saw
Boke is an interactive um visualization
Library written
um written in several languages and
we'll see how everything fits together
but the important part if we compare it
to other visualizations libraries that
exist in the ecosystem is that it
targets the browser and it targets um
being able to to deploy these
visualizations and share them um in the
browser setting so when we think about
the browser we're thinking about HTML
and something that uh that can render
HTML so in order to do that there's this
Library called OK JS which is a
JavaScript library that giving a blob of
Json is able to render uh a
visualization
so in order to write this Json output
you could just like use BJs as is and if
you're a JavaScript developer you can
use it um to write the visualizations in
the in in in your language like
JavaScript but if you're not and you
still want to be able to Target the
browser and get this um cool visualiz
ations that you can share with others uh
but just you know by just having an HTML
page and and a way to serve it um then
you can use all these wrappers and
Bindings that people have um developed
in order to render to Output this J on
that then can Boke JS can understand and
render
it so we have the main of course um Boke
was uh was um targeted in the python
ecosystem so that's like like one of the
the core uh libraries and that's the
python banding is that's what we call
plain bokeh and that's the the main um
my main tutorial talk today is going to
um be about this Boke python um library
but people you know in in other U
languages have also written uh bindings
to be able to you know use their
language to to uh visualize and output
these cool HTML pages and visualizations
so people have created
R bindings and we call that R Boke also
in the organization for Lua Boke Lua
Julia so any language that can output a
Json blob that can BJs can understand is
able would be able to do it you just
need a developer of the language that's
willing to write the the wrapping for
you so a little bit about this tutorial
and how I've I've planned it um as I
said we're going to Focus we're not
going to talk about the bokeh JavaScript
we're not going to talk about other um
bindings we're going to focus on uh the
Boke python
interface and in this Library we um we
encounter different interfaces different
levels of of apis that you can use one
is called the chart and another one that
we're going to see is called the
plotting and then the lowlevel U bouquet
objects that are called models
we're going to see that those interfaces
and see uh why when you would want to
use each of the different interfaces and
um how different they are then um
there's different outputs that uh poke
can give you you can output a file an
HTML file you can output to the uh
IPython notebook um and then there's
this Bokus server that we're also going
to talk more about in more
detail
another another aspect of bouet that
people are interested is well what if I
you know I'm a web developer I have a d
Jango app I have a flask app how do I
add a Boke uh visualization into my
application we're also going to talk
about
that then other people uh you know
there's a lot of people that have
already have a lot of work already done
in other visualization libraries like
Seaborn uh you know uh ggplot matte plot
lip we have a compatibility layer that
allows you to transform those
visualizations that you already have
written in those libraries into a
bouquet plot we're also going to see how
we can do that um and then finally we're
going to see a little bit uh we're going
to go around um you know what what uh
bouet tools are um how we can manage
interactions without needing a server um
how we can lay out visualizations in a
type of dashboard um and then what kind
of properties we can uh use to style our
plots differently that what comes by
default so I hope you're excited this is
going to be kind of the tutorial it's
mainly going to be me give for each of
these sections giving a like a a brief
Theory overview of what what there is
and then being viewing examples and
viewing code and viewing how we can
tweak
it so how do you set up um bouquet so
you have um two options there's cond
install bouquet how many people here
know what K
is okay how many people don't know what
cond
is okay so how many people know the
difference between anaconda and
cond
okay so um just like a brief
introduction um one of the easiest way
to uh get B okay is if you already have
the Anaconda python distribution it
comes with
it and then cond is the package manager
in Anaconda that allows you to install
uh dependencies um and it's pretty neat
because it's language agnostic so you
can cond install right now we have a lot
of support with r so we can con install
R cond install no JS con install um
other languages Scala anything can be
converted into this AA package and um
it's pretty neat to manage especially if
you have dependencies that are on
different languages and you need a kind
of a requirements txt but uh that's able
to manage not only python libraries but
uh any other kind kind of dependency you
can have this um same kind of file
format for everything um if you don't
like for some reason you don't like cond
you don't like Anaconda uh you can also
pep install Bou but be careful that
there's some scipi dependencies make
sure that you know how to install that
properly um I'm leaving you two links
with more information about the
installation so um this tutorial is um
available online um ch. github.io pyata
2015 Berlin Boke um so you can follow
along if you like and you get the uh
URLs and links and everything um it's
also in a GitHub repository so in the
GitHub repository you're going to find
the uh any data that I use in the
examples all the examples oh I think my
internet connection is
not think we're all we're all
connected so there's the examples here
and so all the examples that I'm going
to use are going to be in this folder um
also divided by section so you know um
when you uh uh
here so you have going to have each of
the different sections that I've
mentioned you're going to have uh
examples that come with it uh that you
can run yourself um uh
because it's not just Boke but has other
dependencies uh I have this environment
Yo which is um the the requirements txt
for uh that's able to generalize and not
just be able to handle python
dependencies but any kind of you have a
mongod DV dependency things like that
you can also add it here as your
dependency that will will manage for you
so that I use uh cont environments a lot
um I that's the the talk I gave at Pata
Dallas so if you're interested in
knowing more about content how you can
use it in your workflows um you can you
can uh it's the slides are on my website
and the videos also available at the P
data uh
YouTube page so
so um to set up the tutorial uh all the
dependencies that we're going to use are
available in the Anaconda free
distribution um so for people who uh you
know that the difference Anaconda comes
with a python um version uh cond which
is a package manager that's going to
allow you to install other dependencies
and it comes with already a bunch of
packages uh for scientific Computing and
uh data an analytics uh because that's
like pretty a heavyweight dependency
because you have all these packages an
alternative is you can just use
miniconda which just comes with cond and
Python and then you can manage yourself
what you want to install what what of
the which ones of the libraries you have
in an aond that you'd like to have in
your environment and you can do that
with this um with this environment yl
file that I just showed you and with
just doing cond create and Source
activate B tutorial you're going to get
all the um dependencies without having
the um with a lightweight um alternative
to downloading a full and a cond
distribution um when you install bit bit
comes with some examples and the
examples um you need to download the
sample data in order to run some of them
so here's the the code to um download
the the sample data I'm going to be
using uh Bou version
090 so just make sure you have that
before you try to run the examples uh
there has been a lot of development uh
there was a a pretty um big change in
Zer around 07 so if you have you use
anything previous to that a lot of
things are going to be deprecated or um
not work in
09 so the first the the first section
we're going to talk about is charts and
charts is this high level API that
allows you to draw kind of this
um um these visualizations that are kind
of standard right Scatter Plots uh area
plots bar plots time series uh box plot
donut dot um these are the ones that are
currently
available and
the the neat thing about charts is uh
you need um there's a lot of default
that comes by and just by passing a data
frame or uh dictionary and umpire array
you're able to generate this uh these
plots and Boke is a little bit smart
knows like you know what you mean when
you pass uh you know a data frame uh for
a schedule uh you can pass a group VI to
generate a scle plot uh and knows like
that you mean that the that the labels
are going to be different groups and
things like
that
so let
me uh if I had internet this links
should work
but there no just it's just me or
everyone out of
Internet
okay okay so
um let me I can also build
[Music]
the
here okay
thanks I'm going to build the the
documentation from the bouet
so so in um just so you
see
the um kind of the this is the the
repository uh the bouquet repository
that's available in GitHub you can clone
it um there's the the sphin
documentation
here and you have the REM of how to um
build a doc so if in cases like this
where you're uh run out of the internet
you can
um uh build the documentations anyway so
I can show you make
surve I think
it's well now I'm showing you how I use
cond
um
[Music]
for
oh no I have
the I
know I have the I'm in the inos space is
that
[Music]
correct
yeah what's
[Music]
up good just nobody switches okay
than
[Music]
okay
now okay
cool okay so now I can show you the
online documentation
okay sorry about that I got I got
internet um so this is the uh page the
bou page um where you can find a lot of
the
information um and we were talking about
the charts um
so um I'm just going to give you some
examples following the the documentation
so you see where you can find it to when
um when you want so um as you see you
have some some data
um um we're going to go over like the
different uh output possibilities we've
said there were three output The
Notebook output of HTML file or output
the server
um you can use output the file that
generates an HTML page with the
visualization um and then this uh line
here is the chart uh where you can pass
uh line uh the data that you've
generated uh and a bunch of uh
properties of the plot um if you don't
use the properties just going to get the
default ones and then you you show the
plot and that just turns into this you
know simple line example um and pretty
much all the uh charts
are um use this this simple
structure um there's a bar and Dot
charts um the box plot chart is another
example you pass the data um you get you
get this you know you just have to write
um these four lines of python code and
you get an HTML page with this nice um
visualization that you can share with
with with others um so kind of a just a
heads up up on the state of the charts
um the charts interface is pretty much
the one of the um areas that's being um
heavily developed right now and that's
getting improvements um uh I have to say
that the plotting interface that we're
going to see next and the models those
are pretty stable at this stage and and
there's no uh there were some uh heavy
factoring back in 07 but there's no
plans on um changing or or any of those
because right now that we we found that
um they're in a a um stable
stage um charts is being heavily
developed so um just be careful in in
that sense so one of the benefits of
charge or what's the aim is is being
able to generate very fast um kind of
this set of default visualizations that
exist in this Statistics uh world uh
without having the user Make a lot of
the work uh and having a nice simple
interface for changing things by just
passing like title you know this
properties with
height we have another heat
map this
donut um a Time
series uh several time series in the
same plot which um you can just pass as
a um a panda data frame with um
different uh values so we're going to
see these examples as I said um they're
all available under the
examples um in the uh GitHub repository
for this
tutorial and in charts we're going to
see let's see the time series
one so it's a um how I I'm am just
assuming that people are familiar with
the IPython notebook uh and I don't have
to uh go over that but if someone isn't
let me know um so and how many people
here are familiar with pandas and
numai okay so much everyone um so here
we have append re csb from these um
Yahoo charts with that um is a CSV with
um pricing um of uh different stocks um
so if I run
this you'll see here
here the this Apple
data it's um just a bunch of a Time
series uh dates what was the price of
the stock at Open high low close what
was the volume of stock what was the
adjustment at closed um at Clos um time
so you have this pandas data frame with
a time with a date which is a um the
your X
um your x value in your chart and you
have a um one column which you care
about that you want to plot that's going
to be your y so it's as simple as
passing the data the
two the two columns that you care about
the X and the Y telling it that your
index is actually going to be the date
um and that it shows the it shows the
the plot and it comes with all the cool
um toolbar that we're going to see um
and zoom
in zoom
out um and the ability of well we're
going to go through all of that but just
with this like five lines of python code
you're able to generate this generate an
HTML page that you can then serve and
and
share if you if if anyone has questions
while I'm going please feel free to
raise your hand and uh I'll I'll help
you out
so another
example of a um maybe a little bit more
complex um data structure it's um this
data that uh that comes with um
[Music]
let um different countries uh in this
dictionary and then how many medals they
won at Olympics game um you can see the
country code and then how many bronzes
how many gold Silvers how many was the
total um so this example just um does a
little bit more
um just changes a little bit the the
data structures um you output the
notebook and you get this um order dick
that's what the bar is expecting um and
then what countries that's going to be
your X categorical uh
axis um and there are several ways you
can
input data into this charts one is the
dictionary input another one's the
pendas data frame so you can choose you
know that the data structure that you're
more comfortable with you just need to
check you know in these examples that
you're passing it uh with the same uh
kind of structure of like columns uh or
or rows
so so if
[Music]
we so if I I run this um I get this
stack part chart um with the dictionary
input uh where I can see the countries
how many bronze silver gold they got in
the total with you know just running um
these few um
charts
um as I said said you can also input it
as a pandas data frame instead of a
dictionary um and uh we can see here the
pandas input and also stack and you pass
just a a data Pand data frame if you
don't want it uh stacked and you want it
group then you just need to
change um this stack true to stack false
and you're going to get um this
different orientation
so um charts as you see uh is a very
simple way a very high level interface
of
running um of having this kind of
visualization a histogram um you know
nump uh random uh you have a
distribution of uh random distribution
give it U uh mean mean zero standard
deviation 0 five um and you can see this
plot and then add to it um visualize it
as a pend um data input on array um and
also have uh this nice overlaying of the
theoretical um distribution to be able
to
[Music]
compare so yeah question um so so to me
you talked about being able to get this
on very easily
yes just quick deployment to the folks
that actually need to see the charts
right right like
reactive is
it right so there are um so you can wrap
uh so the the what you're going to get
as um uh as the chart itself can be
wrapped around uh any uh you know any
CSS or any styling that you have so you
can um add you know to Twitter bootstrap
grid the you know wrapped it around it
wrapped around your diff of your um
bouquet plot around it and that's going
to take um care of that um you also have
um you can also set the width and height
uh as a uh you know as a as an option uh
here so you can um manage the those
sizes uh through the property is and
then there's this um
resize resize um tool that you know that
in case like um you know you didn't take
that into account for some you you know
um that resize tool though would that be
accessible by the viewer yeah it is it
[Music]
is
yes exactly so we're going to see that
um in in
the section of like how you embed and
how you uh output mechanisms that you
have uh but yeah you're going to see it
just like a Di and a script that you can
then pass into any of your templates and
you can uh you know lay it out or use
use it in a flask app or um you know any
of your your interfaces
um
so so I think uh you know um if people
around here like you know try try out
something and it doesn't work I'm going
to be around all weekend and you know we
can discuss or if someone tries
something doesn't work um let me know so
um um so kind of that was all for the
chart just like to get the a sense of
what it is um as I said here's the
documentation and examples for it then
we have this um plotting interface which
is I would say uh the one of the most
like stable Parts uh of Bou like has a
uh you know the I API is not going to
change um in the um because it has a a
strong model that uh we build in just
like um just was changed recently 07 um
after getting some user feedback so
basically you start in the plotting
interface you start a plot as a figure
uh it kind tries to resemble a little
bit with people that are familiar with
mat matte plot lip um and and this type
of libraries so you initiate a plot with
a figure um you know you can pass in
some properties to initialize um and
then what you can do to this plot is um
just use the methods that it comes with
to uh add any kind of Cliff um that you
that you want there's these are just you
know some of them you know asteris and
um circles images patches um triangles
and a bunch of more and you just um add
one to your plot by a by doing plot dot
you know that method of that Cliff that
you want to pin and the properties of it
you know what's going to be the X the Y
the size the color and then you're going
to just um show it show plot uh being
decided what kind of output you wanted
if you want the output be an HTML page
the output to be a notebook inside the
notebook or if you want the output to be
managed through the server and we'll see
um more about the server in in a second
so
um just a
quick um here's the plotting with the
basic lifts and this is where you're
going to find information on this
interface and how to create um figures
with it so as as I said it's also um
very it's a little bit lower level than
the charts because it doesn't generate
this like uh already designed um chart
like chart for you and you have to like
be able to like put the pieces together
and say uh you know if you want you know
what kind of Clips you want how you want
it if you want to combine several ones
in in one um so you'll see here output
to a file um what properties you want
append the circle and
show same for a bunch of different types
of of Clips here you have um you know
which ones are available uh the
reference guide is pretty good it's
pretty good uh you can find all the
attributes um on how to use them so here
you have the line you can also have
multiple lines um but just adding more
uh right
here and
showing so
[Music]
um the patches is also a glyph that's
used in order to do a lot of the um
visualizations with um countries and and
regions um so you can pass the um the
EXs and Ys of all the of the polygon of
the points you want to draw that's
what's used to uh some of the
um examples in the gallery you're going
to see that also is also able to render
um
kind of
uh this
um um GE uh locations and and with using
patches so you can use multiple patches
that's how we get the um the
regions um rectangles ovals there's like
all the different uh glyphs that you can
append to your plot using this plotting
interface it's pretty I think that's the
interface that most people are using
right now um and because it's very easy
and very familiar with people that have
been using visualization libraries for a
while so and you can as I said you can
combine several Clips so lines and
circles and you just like uh use both
methods and then show uh this uh this
plot and you're going to have both the
line and the circle so it's pretty neat
if you want a layer kind of thinking it
as layers that you want to put into your
plot
um and here there's a lot of like
information like how you want to set
your ranges um uh right here what kind
of AIS types do you have if it's a
daytime Axis or if it's a uh linear axis
is a if it's a categorical axis um so
you have the datetime which we saw with
the stocks uh so it actually sees you
know can understand years
and dates and the Order of those uh you
can also use log scale axis which a lot
of people uh you know are also
interested
in you can also have twin axes if you
have know you can um add several axes
into one if you have uh different ranges
in in this wanting to visualize
different ranges in the same um in the
same plot and then adding Legends um
it's you can also add Legend uh
just by calling the legend and the text
that you want to show with the
Legend um so that's um pretty
neat so now we've gone through the the
um two first
interfaces um the charts the plotting
um well let me show you if there's some
there's some neat ones uh some neat
examples in the uh plotting
um so
um here we can say we want several
um several lines in the same plot I just
um passed the line the date which is
going to be um this xaxis the uh Y which
is going to be this data that pass what
color and the LED
and then you know I add the title uh
then there's a lot of different
properties that I can set to um uh style
and we're going to see some of them in
the styling section and then um show
show the plot um and you get
this
um same for um other types scatter um
which is going to have all these dots
and you can kind of see here you want to
compare the correlations of these two
two Trends in stocks and see if um
they're both how they're um what's the
correlation between them you want to
visualize that um then you can just um
scatter them and look at
it
um these ones are
um um see is a measure of glucose on a
person um and you can see that they time
and measurements on the glucose so I
can um have these different measurements
uh the viewing this the how these
different values change over over
time um and then I can know I can sty
each of the different U points
separately so I can find well give me
the dates where um I was high and that's
what that's uh this property here the
ones that are that you were low um and
then just plot those and you plot the
entire line of all the um you know all
the dates that you uh you had to measure
and then just by
adding um this scatter on top of it uh
with the Heights on the glucose the size
the color you want to use the same for
um the lows uh and then changing you
know modifying some the properties uh
you get another you know this customized
uh plot um with kind of with relatively
um small amount of python
code um and having other things like if
you want to do a rolling sum you can use
the rolling sum in pandas um you know if
you want to drop the um Na and
um just have this uh line with the index
in the range um and this
[Music]
line um here just a bunch of um like
simple examples of like scatter uh how
you change the color um how you change
the the
glyph um with the marker um marker is
going to what um is going to make the
glyph changed from Circle to square uh
color green so you you see you can
change all those attributes just with a
same method um so kind of that's the
important part of the plotting interface
that um you have a lot of these um
properties already there where that you
can um play around
with
so now uh we're going to the low
interface that's like the core of bokeh
which is called the models and the
models are the bokeh object um
everything in bokeh is a a bokeh uh
model um so even if you see the uh chart
interface or the plotting interface
what's underlying there it's still a
bunch of models um that uh are defined
in the J on blob that gets outputed and
that BJs can understand um and can
translate into uh this visualization in
the on the browser
side so some important um models in the
bouet sphere um there's what's called
sources sources are your data your data
input what's what's the data that you're
going to visualize um and they have this
uh this class that's called column data
source um where you
can reference plots to this source and
so plots within the same with the same
Source can easily um have link Penning
and Link brushing and we'll see um an
example of that so link Penning link
brushing is uh making those two plots
dependent one another just by having the
same
Source um
then that's what's called ranges and
ranges are the
um the ranges of your your plot right
the um what's the how it's going to what
what's the scale that's going to measure
that's going to go in both sides X and Y
um so if you just uh this data range one
this one that's um used that's just like
it's going to Outer fit to the values of
the of your data source
then there's the plot model which is the
um it's going to represent everything
that you add to one plot so all the
other um attributes all the other
objects uh and models that you're going
to put into the the plot are going to be
kind of contained into this object that
we call plot um and plot has several
methods and that's how you um attach
these other objects which are going to
be glyphs layout properties and tools
into your
plot
so um plot at gliph and add U attached
to a source and um a glyph that's also
going to be an object that adds the
glyph to your plot in this lowlevel
interface that you can also
use um then you have um things that are
related with layout like axis then
you're going to append those using the
plot add layout method and you're going
to be able to um put them anywhere you
want your plot below above left or
right um then you're going to also be
able to add the tools that you want into
your plot and the tools can be the a pan
tool a wheel U wheel Zoom Tool uh and
we're going to see all the tools that
are available for
you so as I said um the glyphs are also
object model so um if I use uh in the
example previous example of plot at
glyph um I'm going to have the source
which is the the where the data is
contained it's going to be a column data
source and a circle which is uh a glyph
class um and this glyph class is going
to have properties like what's you know
what's the and
it's each Cliff has its own properties
right the circle is going to have the
the location of it but other glyph is
can have uh you know a patch glyph is
going to have four points able to um in
order to wrapped around where's the area
of where the the patch is going to be
contained so you have to look at each of
the different Cliffs to be
able to um to know what are the
arguments that you're going to have to
pass with that cliff in order to start
it um so you pass um you know those
attributes um and then also styling
attribut like what's the FI color what's
the size what's the uh if you want to
align color around the
circle um axes are also going to be
objects that you're going to pend to
your plot using the add layout um and
you can pick if you want a linear axis
if you want a log scale axis um Etc all
the tools are also going to be class uh
BKE object
models and you have like the pen to tool
to move the uh be able to move the
project the um plot around the wheel
Zoom to be able to zoom in and out of it
um then when you have all those
objects um you add them into a document
and a document is kind think of it as an
HTML page everything that's on that
document uh everything that you put into
that into that HTML page um it's going
to comprehend uh a document so it's just
a a way of saying these are all the
objects the bou objects that are going
to have to be rendered um on the client
side with the bou jsjs Library um and
we're going to see that when you're
using this interface and when you're
using the buus server you're also going
to have to um consider a thing that's
called session and we're going to see in
a little bit um what that
um what that um
is so again we have uh documentation on
the models and in this Boke models
interface you're going to have you're
going to see um all the things I've
talked about and um all the the
properties and um that they have and
that you should uh
initialize or that you can initialize um
if you want so you know each of the
different classes of the different
glyphs have a bunch of attributes of
fill fi colors that some are as Styles
and some others are location or uh the
how it's
um it's going to be displayed like X
cordinates of the center of the um analy
or the Y coordinates of the center um
and then you in this case for example in
this kind of Cliff you're also going to
have an inner radius outer radius so all
that is going to be up to you um how you
uh configure
it
um so we said um you know glyphs are
ones axes are another ones um and we
have also uh tools and a bunch of of
widgets that we can also use um so here
is also the explanation of all the tools
that we're we're going to go uh a little
bit more in deep in depth into uh the
tools later so you know what's available
for you to use um some of the widgets
too um and there's uh buttons um and
drop- down menus um uh dialogue uh
tables icons
and where they appear so so you can use
them so it's up to you these are all op
objects that are available for you to
use right it's going to depend on your
design of your
visualization uh if you want to add some
kind of widget to interact with your
plot so we're going to see some examples
here for for example this one's
um this one's a a um table widget which
has this um table columns uh you're
going to see widgets are described here
the Boke models widgets I've tried to
have um all the sections are equivalent
to a um a file in the bouquet repository
so you can um you know relate the names
with the name space in the in the
repository so models Widgets or are all
this the data table uh table columns um
and in this case here you're going to
see
the the example
here uh which is this um table of your
data and a plot and then um you can
select arrange uh that filters
um and then
um if you
select you're going to be able to uh I
don't know if you see it very well here
but uh they're kind of um the ones that
you don't select are uh have a uh lower
Alpha so you can uh get to know which
ones you're you're selecting um and this
is one type of of widget that's
available to you but there
um there are others um this was kind of
the example that I was following through
the um part on how to um add things to
your glyph add a glyph add a layout add
tools and then you add all those objects
into your document and you uh write uh
out the
[Music]
file
so also in the the bou examples also
fill follow this structure that that I'm
following on the types of examples that
you can find um and the models uh in the
examples for some reason they're called
glyphs and here you can see all um the
examples available um and so you can
see
um another um type of
um wiet um
let's
see I think a lot of some of the widgets
uh or usually the widgets require the
server because you want to use them in
order to interact with your data in some
way uh let's say um you know if I if I
press a button update the data source
behind it um you know and pl and plot it
again so a lot of them um require the
vus server running um and we we'll see
some of them uh in just uh a little
[Music]
bit um so again this is another simple
example of the Irish data set and how
you can create you you know create your
own with this lowlevel interface of
circles adding circles to with the
adlift the layout um and then the same
with the you know your grid if you want
um how you want to
um
configurate your the tickers um and what
kind of tools do you want to add into it
so this one would be just if you want to
run this uh you know the ones that are
not notebooks but are um files um POI
files then you can just do um Python and
run the script and that generates the
the plot in this HTML page for you um so
here we just have two which are the ones
that we we've add it
[Music]
manually
so
as I've been mentioning uh with these
examples you have um three um output um
possibilities uh one is this you know if
you you're using the notebook you can
output to The Notebook if you just want
a static HTML file you can just um
output to a file um this uh methods out
output notebook output file output
server are available across the
different
uh interfaces so you can use them in ch
in charts in plotting and in the models
um API so um and then U charts also adds
uh uh do show um which is also going to
Output um you know you you can add if
you want server notebook or uh file um
as a as an attribute of your chart and
then just show when it's going to do
what what uh what whatever you've passed
um
so uh the interesting part of here is
going to be
the
um looking at the um
server
and so um when do you want the Bokus
server um
let
see um so we're going to see the
resources
here so again here in the um IO you have
the uh explain the output file output
notebook output server um and
and and the bookus server is meant for
um these kind of capabilities when you
want to publish a notebook and have um
other users be able to access the plot
that you're serving um when you want to
do things like uh streaming data uh when
you need to do some kind of down
sampling or some kind of uh process um
uh before you um you send it to the uh
client side um and that's when you have
very large data sets and you want to
things do things like abstract rendering
or um you know more complex um kind of
uh down sampling mechanisms to be able
to uh visualize uh those types of of um
data sets and then sometimes when you
have like some kind of um inter um
dashboard or interaction that uh it
cannot be done with the uh interactions
that no don't need the server so we've
we've been adding more non-server um
interactions so we can kind of relieve
the overhead of having um to have a a
bulus server to run some of the examples
um and kind of like the idea behind it
is you have um you know be able to have
a communication open between the object
graph in the client's side and the
object graph the python object graph in
the server
side um we're developing the this um uh
documentation right now but there's a
lot of uh good examples
um so in each of in the charts plotting
and glyphs um if you go inside of um
each of
them you'll see that
um you have uh always three folders a
file a notebook and a server um and
the the the servers when where you're
going to have these server side examples
not not all that say server uh add an
interactivity because sometimes you just
want the server to be a to be able to
manage different users um hitting the
same document and being uh kind of a
Bokus server the the end point that um
shares everything um so if we go to the
server
um there's some uh examples here and in
order to start
the the B
[Music]
server you just need to run B
server and that starts the bcus server
for you then in
another um in another
uh
um um yeah so you can point to the URL
where where that uh server exists
so you need uh you need that server
running
somewhere it's
yeah it's it's up to you um so if you
want to be the one managing it uh and
the one uh you know uh so you have both
options and that's what uh we're going
to uh see next
um so here in in embed in order to embed
this right now we've just seen notebooks
and files in order to embed them into
your own application you have several uh
options uh one is just getting the as I
said what you need to in order to embed
is just like a script and a div and The
BJs Library um so there's a function
that's called components inside um B
okay then you pass a plot object and
that returns that script and that div um
and
then in a for example a flask example
example where you render a template you
can pass the you know the um the
template that you're using and just
these two um script and div uh and then
add them in your in your HTML template
and using a template engine to add them
um this way um if you're using it this
way you have two options on how you're
going to serve The BJs uh if you want to
serve it in line and have all the um JS
blob um inside of the HTML page or you
want to serve it through our through the
CDN um and then you can pass you can add
another um another variable as the plot
resources and add it also in your uh
embed HTML page and that's going to add
the files from the CDN or if you want to
just like um add them yourself manually
with the links uh these are this is the
URL to do so um another option is you
want to serve it um there's the outload
server which allows you to um store all
the boket plots into the server and then
just passing a tag and this um tag here
is uh going to contain everything
everything uh that needs in order to uh
to render the plot um so that's uh a
neat thing if you want uh to use the
server even you can use it even for
static
plots
so a little bit more about the server
and some more um
examples um
[Music]
um the
tailor
no um so for example the one of the
witch that that we saw was like this um
button here and that just like this um
randomized data so if I click it just um
goes back to the uh back to the to the
server uses some python process uh to do
something just you know get new random
points and then send that back to the uh
to the client um so this is one type of
of widget and that's one of the cases
where you do need the vus server um to
run
um
yeah
um can you can you repeat the question
so basically what I want to
do
yes correct
so uh the Json is actually what gets uh
app so the div and the the script and
the div the div is just a tag of a
location right uh and an ID of the plot
and the um and the the Json the script
is just uh um some JavaScript with a
Json blob and that's what's going to
render all the models um um inside so
you're already getting the um the Json
blob um so you could manage that as as
you'd
like um so another
um
uh um so another one is like if you want
to interact um also between plots and uh
even like if I select one uh you know
one Circle have some interaction with
another uh with another plot um and then
uh you know this uh clicking into one uh
plot updates the other one uh also with
um so um the question is uh talk about
scalability um
so um so that's going to depend I'm not
scalability in terms of how uh how many
users you can um or scalability in terms
of the amount of data set like how large
data set the second one uh so how large
the data set um so more or less um you
can have around 30 30,000 points um I
think that's kind of like the the max
that you that's allowed after that
you're going to need to do some um down
sampling or some abstract rendering
technique in order to get because it's
just going to be a matter of not just uh
loading all those models because each of
the glips are going to be models inside
uh your your your um HTML and page right
that's also like a limiting but also in
terms of viewing things uh if you're
trying to
just output um points you have 30,000
well the visualization itself you're
probably going to have not enough pixels
to actually see it see it right um so
that's when you need some kind of um
Alpha uh you know degration in order to
see to get a sense of um distribution of
points um and that's when you use um
some some you know either down sampling
technique or um
or abstract rendering which is a library
it's it's part of bouet but being it's
still in a research phase and it's being
developed um there's several examples um
on the documentation uh let me see if I
find
it
um it's
called abstract
rendering
[Music]
um
um and there was
a there is um there exist
um a tutorial just uh on abstract
rendering that was given
um that's not
this mainly on on uh
Contours um Alpha uh deoration to
um to get that sense uh so let me see if
I find
[Music]
it I'll I'll add that ref it's the
reference
gu forgot where where it is I just found
it
um recently
but
um it's it's actually the core of the
abstract rendering exist in in a
separate repository but I can also add
that information um so let me show you a
a couple of other
um I think that also going to
use
so for example another another um cool
one that um has this
um selection option that I can select uh
you know a couple of um my points and
then I have another plot next to it that
uh gets um um gets updated with the
those values just those values and you
can see um the distribute you know kind
of make that exploratory analysis
um and then there's
the
so that's that's sort of like a filter
right so you have the drop down option
filter by category yeah uh let me find
them the reason I ask about that is
because I'm I'm more interested in what
you guys have done with
Jitter um because I use a package on the
r side and it's the filter doesn't work
with jittering points and I'm wondering
if you guys are taking care of that on
on Bo cap
um so what do you mean by
diering um so if you have a lot of
points that just have you want to see
the
overall a lot of different points but a
lot of them have the same value so you
just want to see that for example at
that particular point it's not just one
point it's actually nine different
points that are the same value so you do
jittering that actually slightly Alters
the position of every single one
oh I
see so um I think we've taken the route
uh the the route of um doing more of uh
the down
uh uh dis abstr rendering technique
where you can see those distributions uh
by changing the alpha so you know like
how many points are there based on how
dark uh the region is uh rather than
like moving them apart then you're um I
think that's the the the approach um
we've taken
um
so I
think okay let me see
[Music]
okay server
here
[Music]
so another of the examples of using the
uh buus server is when you have some
kind of data that gets updated and you
want to update the visualization with it
um so um this is also an example that we
have uh that exist um in the you
know by using um the the B server um
and right right here just uses a an
infinite L of um changing the data so
you can see uh how that uh gets gets
updated um there's another
example
um
[Music]
here
so we have the server
examples
um so this is another uh I think you
were someone was asking about the drop-
down possibilities um so for example
this is a a data set on the distribution
of population in different places of the
world for female and male and age age
range and uh you have this possibility
to filter by year location um um and
so we can select uh several um places um
and that gets updated uh through the
bcus server um so if we look at
the
um in order to do kind of this more
complex examples there's more code
involved than like the the simple ones
because you have to take care of
updating all the bouet objects
accordingly um to the the changes that
that occur um so in this case we have
have uh as I said in the cases of um
servers you have the notion of a session
and a session in a snapshot uh of the
document at is a a connection to the um
to the document from one user so several
users can be connected can try and
visualize the same document they each
get their own session so if you're um or
they could get the same section session
if you want if you pass it the the
appropriate um session right so that you
can um
visualize independently or uh in common
if if you want it to um so in this case
we get the data the we initialize the
variables of uh the drop- down menu uh
with some year or location
um this one here is the generation of
the the plot itself and uh as you see it
looks a lot of um has the same structure
that what I mentioned in the models uh
part with with um uh generating a plot
and then adding all these different
either layouts or glyphs um uh Legend um
and returning the
plot um then you initialize the
um the um column data sources and we
have a place here when we're going to
update the pyramid information we're
going to change those data sources the
data in those column data sources and
that's what um triggers the change in
the plot changing that um column data
source um so there's two I don't know if
it's there's two plots here this one's
what the one that's called permid um the
one in the bottom it's what's called um
the um prediction the this s um Source
predicted um
[Music]
and um so we're going to update the
permit it's just by updating this data
in the column data source that what
triggers the the
change um so when you change the data
you're going to um update the population
data update the the pyramid data um and
then you're going to store in in the
session that you're seeing store this
new uh this document um with those
changes
um and you get like kind of these
functions of like when uh I change the
year I'm going to update the data when I
change location I'm also going to update
the data and then you get this um layout
of um the select or the um drop- down
menus um on change means one those
change um I'm going to um update the um
the values uh and then I have the
controls in a hbox which is a layout
mechanism of saying horizontal box and
the V box is a vertical box and then I'm
going to have the controls in the
vertical box the pyramid plot and the
population plot and I'm going to return
this
layout um so in the document uh this
document I'm going to add the layout and
then just like um call update data and
uh um there's some some nice TS to uh
view links um
and um pull the document to see the
changes
so
um I've shown that
[Music]
one this one similar to the one I
mentioned earlier
um
um so another another important section
is the um compatibility um layer and as
I said uh if you have old matplot LIF um
Seaborn um or
ggplot um that you have available um and
for we have this simple example here of
a map plot um Lip lip figure um just by
changing this last line to um uh this
ml2 Boke you get the Boke plot of it um
that's a pretty neat uh feature we have
um here
compat
so I have all my python notebooks
um
so
um up till here it's all M plot LIF and
then I I do this show M plot LIF to B
so um I'm going to get yeah how do you
manage to uh reload
javascri access
javascri
youas Oh you mean how it's done um so
it's loaded uh see here uh it says uh
when you call um Boke plot plotting in
um in the notebook uh it runs the the
loading of the JS into it
[Music]
oh the just that um so if we look at
here uh on the
um JavaScript um on on the HTML we are
going to find the um all the um I python
notebook stuff but then also um the bou
um part so um if I look at
the uh poke canvas um you know poke
generates all this like plot um div ID
and then uh with this div and the
JavaScript all these different um divs
and tables and classes get generated
with the bouet plot wrapper uh canvas uh
canvas wrapper uh Etc so all these are
the and then this is generated with a a
script that's uh up here
[Music]
so there's a lot of
um um that's one of the pain points of
the The Notebook that's we we have to um
make sure that we don't uh you know that
we're we're compatible that's why
there's the the special uh output
notebook that's different from the
output file because uh you you might be
some um maybe name space crashes between
the uh IPython notebook uh you know
styling and yours uh things like that so
let me see if I find
the
um so you can export the um you can
export each of the plot uh uh as an
image so
uh I'm not sure that if you use the
IPython notebooks uh for you know format
exporters that it's going to
automatically do that for you of
generating uh I don't think it it does
right now of uh generating you know
creating the uh image format file then
putting it where it's appropriate
um yeah
so
maybe it's the
[Music]
script so okay here's the blob so this
um this one here it's hard to see uh you
can look at it yourself in each of the
uh if any of the examples and you this
uh style here this is the B CSS
um style and then there's the
um JavaScript the vouet um
JavaScript right here and this is all
what uh what generates the um you
know where's
the and here's the so that's the CSS the
JS and this is the the script for your
particular plot and you see you have um
let's see
if here so um you have the model ID you
have the the type the plot and then you
have all these different models that we
have appended in one document uh and
with all their attributes um so this is
all the like the The Blob that gets
generated then the J s and the CSS can
interpret to make the plot so this is
the um so this is what what gets
rendered um this thing here uh so that
does that answer your question
okay um so we were looking at a
different examples for the compatibility
um
layer and we have the um
here this one
here um so as we said we have this uh M
plot LIF figure in bouquet um there's a
you know this um line collection which
is also written in matte plot lip and
you just add this um last line um to
make the
change um also there's also these
polygons
um uh that were also generated with M PL
Li that can translate to uh both okay um
there's also
pandas um
no pandas can also uh PL also through um
mat PL lip and then you can um make the
transformation too so um when you're
exploring uh your data frames uh you
cannot just generate the the static view
but also these ones uh this PO plots to
be able to to share which is um pretty
neat and then there's this other Library
that's also used in statistical analysis
that's called Seaborn um and you can
also use that um you get this seor like
uh bouet plots uh and all you write up
you know all all this is comes from the
um comes from the Seaborn
library and even um C library has this
violent plot so you can
also uh use it to you know and translate
it to uh a bouet if there's a feature
that you want in that library and you
still want to publish it and you don't
have capabilities in it um then you just
like uh do that translation to Boke um
and that's that's
[Music]
it so
another thing I wanted to talk about is
[Music]
the
um as also here you have the where in
the documentation you can find more
information about it and the
examples um the final section was about
um looking deeper into all the tools
that are available uh what kind of
interactions are possible without
needing the bcus server uh how you can
lay out the different plots in your page
and a little bit about the styling
so here are all the the tools that are
um available in in Boke um there are
tools that are
um about pen drag drw and drag your plot
to click around um to um when you scroll
um and some actions and what they call
inspectors so I think the best way to
understand what each one does just by
looking at a plot that has um several of
them
so here
in
tools I have that color plot in a
notebook
so um so his one this one here um in the
in the as I said in the models library
to um add a tool you use that plot dot
at um at tool if you're using the
plotting API it's easier you can just um
set the tools uh like with a string and
with the name of the tool you
want um and and that's going to that's
going to set the tools for you uh and
you pass the tools into your figure and
that's going to add all those those the
to the available tools so the first one
is pen pen is about moving being able to
move your uh plot around um you have the
lasso select um which is a way of
selecting just a
couple
um you have the box Zoom which I can use
to um zoom in in a with a box um I we've
seen that one before the resize
one so I can resize the plot
interactively the wheel Zoom which is
going to let let me with use my uh you
know Zoom in and out with with a
wheel um tap which is going to make be
able to select um different points in my
data set
um
the um reset button which uh resets it
to the um like the starting point um you
can
also um as we said save and preview so
if you've done something you can now um
you know save images and you can uh
decide how you want to save it a PNG
whatever and then there's this a cross
the cross here is these like two lines
uh that we see here when I'm moving I
can deselect that and then I don't have
it anymore
um
um so um these are all the tools tools
that are available and as we said if you
want just some of them in using the
models Library you add them if if you're
using the plotting you can just like um
have a string with the list with all the
um tools separate by a common that will
um add the the appropriate you know the
tools that you want
um so for the lasso effect any
other plot that's like a grid like
nearby that's being affected by that
lasso like it's showing the distribution
of whatever you lasso yeah so it's not
going back to the server for that data
is it so uh no it doesn't need to no
because that's already known in the um
uh but on any filter it is going back to
the server in any filter yeah because
you're performing then a python
operation with pendas to or what
whatever you're using uh to do so I
think I had left one
open um
so that's why we're adding more um
interactions that um don't need uh the
Bokus server and we just use like um
this the callbox is pretty new um after
I think was added after uh
Pyon in order to add more of these uh
interactions with widgets without
needing you know a running server in the
in the back end um so in the
interactions
uh I also have
the we can see different
examples
here
um
so um there's several
uh uh different interaction
possibilities this what's called between
plots one's called uh linked brushing
which means if I select
uh items of the selection of items on
one plot is going to allow me to do
something in another plot with them so
um for example if this last select if I
uh you know select this ones here I'm
able to see that they correspond to
these values up here in the other plot
um uh if I you
know uh look at uh you
know this um couple of here I can see
that there are these two lines um and
that is happening without the need of
the B server
running um link P panning um is just
being able to um uh move them around and
that they will like uh all the different
plots will like also move around
um uh the in the um user guy there's a
good
um uh
there's a good explanation on this
available interactions and like with an
example it's always easier um to
understand we've seen this link panning
and L link
brushing um and then there's um this um
actions that you can use for example um
this one here tells you click the dots
and click the dots um with this code
here it's going to um you know you're
going to be able to select with the tab
tool and then the action that's going to
come from it it's open a specific URL so
if I click this dot here and I have
internet uh then uh so uh then it's
going to open a URL as I as I click it
so I have this action possibility um
available to me too um then on the
widget side um things like sliders um
you can actually add this uh call back
um as uh
as a class uh it's a it's a Boke model
now um and you can actually uh add the
code that you want to run as your um as
your call back um and if I move this
slider around you know this is going to
uh do something it's going to run this
code as I change the value um so that's
also a
possibility um and this is without the
need uh with the B server which is
something that has changed just recently
um to be able to use this call back now
um for for selections um you
can uh you know select things
here um and it's going to get uh the
same data just like the ones that uh
that you want and output this uh in the
in the other plot um and you have here
the the code that gets uh executed when
I do a select in in the first
[Music]
one
so I think that's it uh inter the simp
interact
basic this is another uh that makes use
of the IPython available widgets um also
with combination of the Boke uh
visualization and I can here now select
the you know what function I want um and
then what you know the different
parameters uh that I can uh
select
um so that's another
[Music]
example
um there's um different uh layout
possibilities as I said there's the the
V plot so if you want to combine plots
one on top of the other one uh just use
the V plot and uh set the different
plots uh then there's the H plot um
which does the same but horizontally and
then you can also use the grid plot uh
and you can select what which plot goes
in into each grid and also have a non a
non plot so you have an empty an empty
space if you like
um
so uh in here we're going to see
layouts uh like the this is an example
of the grid plot so you can uh you know
create the different figures uh that we
saw this using the plotting API the
different figures that you want uh you
uh add uh in each figure a different
glyph the anal W the visier the quad and
then you you uh with the grid plot you
just specify um what do you want in in
each in each place of your grid so if I
run this
um I'm going to see this
um um you know four different uh plots
uh with two empty spaces in
in the grid
um and you know and you can arrange kind
of a dashboard like style of your plots
and how you want them distributed in the
in the
page um and the final sections on
styling styling dashboards um and
there's
a all the attributes of styling are
available um here and you can see
all the line properties that you want
color with um know Alpha if how
transparent you want the um how you want
to fill the colors of the um different
glyphs text properties so if you want to
change the font of the title you can do
so
um uh so uh here's also in the plot
inself you can change the dimensions
we've seen that change the title font um
and color and style the background of
your
plot um the outside border uh if you
want different style you can create your
own uh you know if you don't like the
default style of bouet and you want to
create your own uh you know you can also
do that um an outline on the plot can
also be changed the different glyphs can
you know have different uh contour and
and
filling um you can also U change the the
axis the color of the axis line the
color of the
values
um the you know the the bound the
boundaries of the of the axis so you
just get uh you know the the middle ones
um how you want the ticks The Tick lines
of your plot so if you wanted them red
the semi ticks yellow uh that's also
possible they're all all these
properties are exposed to you uh you
know just by doing uh the P which is the
figure uh the axis you know and major
and then there's
uh all the properties are are exposed in
that way because they're there's they're
all objects um and there's attributes of
of your
objects um so you also can change the
different thick form matters you know
percentage wise or uh you know um if you
want um some scientific uh not ation you
if you want them uh you know with some
orientation like uh the major labor
orientation if you want them uh you know
vertical align um the the grid lines
also if you want no grids or if you want
them with a certain
property um bands um you know different
also boundaries um the The Legend you
can also decide where uh where's the
orientation of the legend bottom left
top
right the the actually the text of the
legend can also be changed uh so there's
um you know you can definitely um style
your plot uh as you like uh with all the
you know properties and make it look um
you know look um nice with whatever we
website or web page that matches the the
CSS that you're using uh
so I think we I have five minutes for
questions or something like
[Music]
that so if someone has a question yeah
just AIT the pl first of allce to have
something that is similar to show and
cont M now right now there is an image
thing but it's not exactly
doesn't have a color
bar levels plans to imp something like
this gra or in charts
interface and the second question is
about support of map proection is like
this
supportting from
fut so um there you had two questions
the first one is uh image
support oh okay so that's I don't think
that's in like the uh the next uh in the
road map right now um there has been
like other priorities um to get it um uh
running and and kind of like there's
also kind of the the notion that um that
the that um that or at least the
priorities that Boke has been on getting
that information on your data using
other techniques not um uh so kind of
like if you project it and get like a
sense of like density rather than uh
that that uh you know those Dimensions
like that so um and the question about
the the second question uh was on uh the
map
projections so right now uh in the
geospace uh in Boke there's um what's
called the gmap plot which is just a um
Google Map plot that you can use um uh
and add and add and add any glyph on top
of it and then there was a um an
integration with um
gjs um but that's uh that was kind of a
a collaboration with um the gojs guys
and uh not not sure we've had users of
the the gojs port um and then you have
the be able like making the Contours
yourself with patches so that's kind of
the state of the um any uh Geo art and I
can show you
the the
um the GMAT plot
um um not a lot of um I don't think we
we should we have to add an example
because it's something people have been
adding and we haven't uh have a like a
visual in the gallery and I think
there's a lot of people that are asking
for that
[Music]
um um I think
it's
[Music]
close
there's the tmat
[Music]
plot let me
see glips
[Music]
maps
no
[Music]
so this is the the the capabilities
right now so you can add layers on top
of this uh Google Map uh and you can add
uh you know um you could add polygons or
you could add uh lines uh any of the
existing lifts um
and you have the if you zoom out a lot
um you know just looks it's not capable
to identify exactly where it is but um
so that's yeah that's some some mapping
um capabilities
there
yeah
so yeah right now like um the the kind
of the low level apis they're ready and
you can create uh you know create your
own and even uh more of like novel
Graphics uh you know custom um things
and you can see some of the gallery um
like you know this you know this thing
here's like the the the code of it for
it um and it's this one's using the the
plotting um the plotting interface and
there's just like a lot of style changes
but you have like it's just like anular
um the circle adding text um so this can
already be you know can already be done
it just a matter of people generating
more examples so and people sharing them
and adding them to the gallery and
having some some kind of uh common space
for uh you know people um to look at
easily to examples that look at similar
to what their their needs are um you
know I think that's probably um where
where the three really has um uh strived
having uh the Michael uh the Box page
with all the examples that has made a
lot of people just like you know use
getting it and just like changing the
pieces that you need for your your
custom um and kind of like the idea is
that we have um developed the like the
foundations of it right now the models
API is table the um and now it's a
matter of uh the plotting is stable and
kind of like the the charts interface is
kind of wanting to have those like um
you
know having those examples of like you
could create you know you can create
custom
um uh these custom novel graphics and
then just provide in your user with a uh
you know a nice uh wrapper around it
that they could just like shove their um
their their data in and reuse it so that
you know if we have more uh support of
people uh helping build those reusable
charts or um posting more of their their
visualizations and code think that that
will start having more of that uh you
know that what D3 has had um
so yeah the the it's a you can submit a
a pull request that the it's um the
website is the the docs that are um so
if you go to the here the the Sphinx uh
page here's where the the source of the
uh dogs are so you could um um there's a
Ser server
um gather with some
um
and
um so it's um you know if you have
examples like we are accepting PRS on uh
you know on more examples of what people
are doing um there's a lot a lot of the
examples that we have in the gallery are
actually made by uh users and not uh not
as um like I
think there's like you know you can do
things like you know this uh a periodic
table
or
um I think like the the heat
map
[Music]
um um so yeah I think now it's up to the
community to start generating more more
content and more examples for um you
know to get into this that stage of
usability that uh D3 has
and
yeah um so you can um I think that the
road map is uh released uh
here
um there
was here noad map uh so you can see what
are the goals for like the summer um I
don't I don't see I haven't seen a a um
comments on um you know there's of
course there's long-term to-do list and
uh we can add uh those kind of of um
you know wish is there but like
realistically for the goal Zone this
this summer uh they're uh basically this
um so no not I don't see it in the short
term um but if there's you know it's
kind of Al starting the conversation in
like the mailing list and kind of
pushing also libraries um to do what the
users uh you know fulfilling the pain
points of of the users that are having
with other libraries and kind of trying
to help there so you you should start
the conversation the mailing
list okay I think
we're
um so if anyone has any other questions
we going to leave it
here okay thank
[Applause]
you thank
you than you to
Christina